[Musique]
non mais ça va pas mais vous prenez pour
qui ouvrir les ordinateurs des gens
comme ça donnait vois ça non mais vous
savez pas tant mais vous avez vu vous
avez vu là
[Musique]
bonjour méthane votre mission si vous
l'acceptez est d'accomplir votre [ __ ]
de femmes votre mission si vous
l'acceptez est de trouver un microfilm
essentiel celui ci se trouve dans le
bureau de l'ambassade sud il contient
des informations sensibles sur une taupe
au sein de l' agence comme toujours si
vous ou l'un de vos agents est capturé
durant cette mission le gouvernement
n'ira avoir eu connaissance de vos
agissements maintenant il n'est pas trop
tard pour agrandir votre béni
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur l'ambassadeur
mais selon masters
monsieur l'ambassadeur qu'elle soit
riman
[Musique]
samba le monsieur l'ambassadeur
bin hamman
[Musique]
l'opposition
c'est bon j'ai l'ambassadeur en visuel
hockey ton déguisement fonctionne
parfaitement maintenant tu dois discuter
en place in camera je m'occupe si un
plan
regardez la bartère baladeur
[Musique]
c'est bon génial
parfait
là je
j'ai plus la cible un visuel je suis tu
[Musique]
ok c'est bon j'ai le kon tum bayonnais
moi
[Musique]
je
et vous
il mais voilà le digicode attention ne
trompent pas sinon ça déclenche l'alarmé
c'est parti après
c'est bon je suis dans la salle des
serveurs de champagne petits fours
[Musique]
c'est bon j'ai microfilms du tout le
monde quand on pense à mission
impossible on pense en général
immédiatement au film avec tom cruise
mais les plus anciens se souviendront de
la série qui a fait les beaux jours de
m6 à la fin des années 90 qui est elle
même la suite de la série des années 60
il s'agit en gros d'un groupe nommé inf
qui effectuent des actions d'espionnage
pour le gouvernement américain à la
série a était très connu pour ses
gimmicks comme le truc du message qui
s'autodétruit dans cinq secondes où le
générique avec la mèche et pour un
développeur de jeux vidéo à la licence
c'est cadeau un groupe de gentils qui se
bat contre des méchants en utilisant des
flingues et des gadgets le jeu il est
déjà fait et pourtant paradoxalement le
premier jeu mission impossible vraiment
connu et bien c'était pas vraiment un
jeu mission impossible c'était un jeu
avec un agent secret qui se bat contre
des méchants qui s'infiltrent dans une
base en utilisant des ordinateurs et des
gadgets et qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on
n'a pas la licence mission impossible
mais qu'on veut quand même faire penser
un jeu mission impossible
[Musique]
c'est dû gêner
le premier vrai jeu mission impossible
arriva sur nes en 90 j'essaie de jeu
d'action infiltration en vue du dessus
sur le même modèle que le monde
extérieur de tortues ninja sur nes avec
des grands mères qui te poursuis mon
couteau et un sens des proportions un
peu étrange
[ __ ] la vache c'est quoi ce billard
c'est quoi cette can on dirait un tronc
d'arbre et après ça eh bé plus rien rien
sur 16 bis la liste ans tombe
complètement dans l'oubli jusqu'à la
sortie du premier film en 1996 et à la
sortie du jeu suivant sur nintendo 64 et
vous savez bien qu'en général quand on
parle de la nintendo 64 on pense
immédiatement à mario 64 zelda ocarina
of time ou goldeneye est mission
impossible aurait bien aimé y être dans
cette liste il aurait dû en fait à
l'épeuve le jeu mission impossible est
vendu comme un énorme blockbuster il ya
de la pub partout dans les magazines et
même à la télé du coup je vais essayer
d'être parfaitement juste dans ma
critique je vais m et si un peu d'heures
et je n'appuierai dessus que quand le
jeu sera
extrait infogrames rachète océans le jeu
mission impossible est dans un état
catastrophique déjà été récompensé deux
fois et c'est donc un studio français
qui le récupère avec pour mission d'
enfin le terminer donc je résume c'est
un jeu à licence sur ip qui arrive avec
deux ans de retard après avoir changé
d'équipement catastrophe pour être
développée par infogrames
[Musique]
je commence donc par une cinématique de
tim faible ce qui reçoit une mission
avec le fameux passage persique des
missions impossibles du truc et s'auto
détruira dans cinq secondes
ne fait jamais ça en vrai
alors cela dit une chose avant de
commencer j'ai eu ce jeu moi même quand
j'étais gosse et je l'avais même aimé et
la presse aussi l'avait beaucoup aimé
sommes en train d'amorcer une des plus
glorieuses heures du jeu vidéo je peux
vous l'assurer le disait ce jeune
journaliste du nom de gollum donc le jeu
est un tps ou third person shooter où
vous dirigez ethan hunt pouvait courir
tirer sauter des trucs classiques le
côté intéressant du jeu ce n'est pas la
baston c'est le côté infiltration selon
la mission vous serez emmené à prendre
l'identité d'autres personnages et le
coeur de certaines missions va reposer
là dessus justement donc après le
premier niveau tresserre de tutos qu on
passe au second niveau ici faible soit
la mission de s'infiltrer dans une
ambassade russe capturé ou tué mais
quand c'est super quand on fait comme
teddy de communication non on est
d'accord que la majorité elle entend
foule a
sérieusement ne fait jamais ça en vrai
on commence donc par une infiltration en
bonne et due forme en devant neutraliser
un assassin et en cherchant quelqu'un
dont il faut prendre l'identité à la
haye sont bien cachés mon plan est
parfait la condition que personne n'ait
envie d'aller aux toilettes dans les dix
prochaines heures en fait le problème de
ce jeu c'est pas tant qu'ils soient
mauvais ou très durs comme dans le jdj
habituel c'est plus qu'il a été vendu au
genre entièrement sur son intelligence
artificielle alors que cette
intelligence artificielle et peut-être
une des pires qui ait jamais existé par
exemple une fois que vous avez récupéré
le costume de labasa d'heures donc vous
vous infiltrer dans le coeur de
l'ambassade en passant par cet énorme
sous-sol rempli de flaques de plutonium
et de caisse d'uranium que je fais péter
à coups de flingues qui explosent en
relâchant des gaz radioactifs dans
toutes les ambassades
mais pour les gardes savard forget
expliquant arrêter de porter cette fois
que dr young est en revanche dans le
niveau suivant on est en plein milieu de
l'ambassade donc ça devrait aller mais
soudainement les gars dans un éclair de
lucidité quand vous rentrez dans un
cagibi
comment marche ce monde c'est un cagibi
bordel de merde meilleur le but est
niveau et de retrouver la clé des champs
alors mais ce n'est pas une expression
il faut littéralement retrouver une clé
qui s'appelle la clé des champs ensuite
vous devrez récupérer 20 grammes de
poudre d'escampette
je les mériter oui à partir de cette
mission vous serez aidé par l'autre
grand point fort de l'intelligence
artificielle de ce jeu candice à candice
quand vi j'ai rarement détester
quelqu'un autant que toi qu'en dise
alors qu'andy s'est décrit comme un des
meilleurs agents de mission impossible
mais qu en dise c'est surtout un énorme
plots candice fait partie de cette
catégorie 10 à que tu vas en permanence
devoirs surveillés comme un espèce de
bébés suicidaire qu'en dit ça va ce
reste pas sur l'étal piégée
mais qu'en dit ça ne me rend pas tout
dit
de monsieur rêve c'est pas vrai c'est
tout ma gueule c'est même pas que l'ia
est mal codé et ces cas n'a juste pas en
fait je vous présente un des meilleurs
agents de mission impossible candice
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors figurez-vous qu'en fouillant un
peu on peut retrouver des interviews des
développeurs qui disent même si c'est un
jeu un players en multijoueur nous avons
essayé de simuler la coopération des
équipes avec les autres membres je lui
régler son compte
on
attendait quelque chose avait quelque
chose
ok vous savez quoi le mieux c'est de
demander directement à la personne qui a
écrit ce article
[Musique]
laissez moi partir pourquoi tu veux
partir de papier avec nous abu bakar
julien j'ai retrouvé ton article tu veux
me faire un peu la lecture
plus fort de son côté intelligence
artificielle
a bénéficié d'un soin tout particulier
on est en droit de s'attendre à quelque
chose de transcendant
chaque personnage dispose d'une
personnalité différente qui influe sur
ses gestes par action ça va influencer
ceux des autres individus est ce que ça
veut dire ça julien sait faire
d'ailleurs on notera que l'article parle
aussi du jeu comme un jeu de commando
non violent c'était beaucoup appuyé dans
la communication du jeu hein ce côté non
violent qui est assez ironique quand on
sait que la mission d'un bassin consiste
à prendre l'apparence d'un type est de
tuer un max de gens afin de faire porter
le chapeau à quelqu'un d'autre ce qui
est littéralement la définition du
terrorisme a donc je crois que ce qu'ils
appellent non violence est juste que
dans certains niveaux tu dois endormir
les gardes avec des fléchettes
tranquillisantes enfin ou des piqûres
endormante marqué dans l'article quoi si
pas comme ça et d'ailleurs ça doit être
les mêmes gars qu'à l'ambassade parce
que vous pouvez les endormir 15 fois
d'affilée sans qu'il se pose aucune
question où en plus je sais pas ce que
j'ai aujourd'hui je suis crevée mois
bref donc le jeu est pas terrible certes
mais j'arrive presque pas lui en vouloir
parce qu'au bout d'un moment j'ai
commencé vraiment trouvé ça drôle au
niveau de la guerre vous aurez droit à
un truc un peu original plutôt que
étonne vous contrôlerez des snipers et
vous devrez protéger et anne des
terroristes en faisant attention à ne
pas abattre les civils qui auront
tendance à me courir dessus depuis
l'autre bout de la gare pour dégainer
leur jambon beurre de mangue c'était un
9 mm
[Musique]
ok alors bon jusque là ça va mais qu'est
ce qui se passe dans cette [ __ ] de
gare les gens courent partout en rond
tape des sprints s'arrête brutalement
change de direction toutes les deux
secondes
il est train pour rennes en trouvant
gars voient quatre
voies de correction
les gens ils sont chila dans cette gare
parce qu'il ya quand même des gens qui
se font abattre par dizaines par un
sniper et tout le monde s'en branle
annoncé par notre mère qu à gare du nord
enfin vrai visiblement il n'y a pas que
les civils qui sont perdus votre
personnage l'est aussi comme ce qu'il
est juste censés aller prendre un train
c'est tout c'est ça sa mission prendre
le train mais pourquoi il se promène
alors oui sauf une bien belle gare 1
personne sur 5 dans cette [ __ ] de
garçons des terroristes à gaza c'est
quoi tous ces gens qui m'agresse alors
d'ailleurs j'ai pas précisé mais si vous
ne vous souvenez pas tout ça dans le
film il ya une raison c'est que ça n'est
jamais arrivé venant du film on retrouve
juste la scène très célèbre avec les
lasers qui est en plus terriblement
frustrante parce qu'il faut constamment
se balancer pour atteindre certains
nombres de la pièce que donne l'air co
[ __ ] on dirait un sauteur pour bébé en
plus j'ai énormément galéré à trouver
comment allumer l'ordinateur parce que
déjà le bouton pour allumer le pc se
trouve à côté de la porte qui est peu
parlement idiot mais surtout votre
personnage refuse de cliquer dessus si
vous n'avez pas le pixel de votre nez
pile dessus il est bordé là puisque seul
truc devant toi là qu'est ce que tu
crois que tu es demande de fermer quoi
je ne comprends pas ce que vous voulez
que je fasse au yoyo et vous souvenez de
cette scène dans le film assez classe
j'ai hâte de leur faire dans le jeu
non
pourquoi il ya un bébé sauteur dans la
salle des serveurs et j'ai pas abordé le
problème numéro un finalement c'est la
maniabilité alors c'est assez difficile
à expliquer sans avoir le jeu en main
mais en gros contrairement à goldeneye
sorti un an avant qu'il y avait un
système d'autos locke mission impossible
n'en possèdent pas et viser les ennemis
va très vite être extrêmement pénible
alors tant que vous êtes dans les phases
d'infiltration le jeu donnent l'illusion
d'être jouable mais dès que vous arrivez
dans des phases d'action chaque ennemi
aura toujours le temps de vous placer
une ou deux balles avant que vous
réussissiez à viser correctement et vu
dans certaines missions les ennemis
arrivent en boucle dans le jeu devient
mission impossible
[Musique]
non sans déconner c'est vachement dur
dans la mission du treuil a
simultanément des ennemis devant moi des
hélicoptères des mets qui me tire dessus
depuis des voitures
dont deux hélicoptères eh bien je
suppose que je vais mourir alors
d'ailleurs vous noterez que le chauffeur
du train à notre passé l'été
à lesquels exclusives ont trouvé cette
fois bref alors j'ai dû finir le jeu
avec le mode à 20,6 là parce que le
dernier niveau est extrêmement dure et
comporte 1 millions d'objectifs
différents ave le schéma il écrit
trouver les exploser et la baule harry
la centrale et les l'alimentation des
communes un lien entre la maladie et la
fia
et je vous avoue qu'à ce moment là du
jeu à la magie du jeu d'infiltration s
est évaporée depuis longtemps
buté j'étais un connard toute façon
et on finit donc le dernier niveau sur
un passage où vous détruisez tous les
bâtiments de la cote à tout cas non sens
allez les enfants répétez après moi je
de commando non violent
et c'est fini
[Applaudissements]
une scène post crédit il ya une scène
post crédit ce t-shirt là ce logo c'est
le développeur du jeu je suis erwan
benoît va avoir des bugs à fixer sans
déconner à roanne j'aime la tartiflette
les lois de l'immigration sont trop
stricte vous pourriez confirmait pas
configuré saurait tarder est tout seul
j'ai une question pour vous qu'est ce
que fout si je non en fait
ok que monde et art et en fait c'est ça
la réponse d'ailleurs je me demande si
[Musique]
bon
où
[Musique]
e
sans radar
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon sang le traître et c'était
et oui c'était moi maintenant tu vas me
remettre le microfilm bien gentiment je
vous prie monsieur de bien vouloir
accepter ce micro film avec tous mes
remerciements un gentiment tu crois que
gagner mais ce que tu ne sais pas c'est
que je ne suis pas vraiment moi
à oui mais tu n'es pas le seul
bien joué mais ça ne change absolument
rien si maintenant tu n'as plus ton arme
ah merde
shaw
un
le bonhomme monsieur
je
[Musique]
cordis je savais que je pouvais compter
sur vous mais comment vous avez su
évidemment
[Musique]
félicitations je savais que je pouvais
compter sur vous vous êtes de loin notre
agent le plus brillant votre prochaine
mission si vous l'acceptez est de
retrouver mon chat monsieur moustache a
été aperçue pour la dernière fois dans
les rues de belgrade en compagnie d'un
célèbre tueur à gages russe molotov
russe corovic ce message s'autodétruira
dans cinq seules ou bonne chance comme
ici
[Musique]
je
et
à
[Musique]